we're going to begin this hour with our
exclusive interview we love when this
happens with Charles Kelly you know him
from the country music group lady a
[Music]
word
never get over you that's lady A's hit
song what if I never get over you I love
this group they've been making music
together for 17 years now last August
you may know the trio postponed their
tour to allow their band mate Charles
Kelly to seek treatment for alcohol
abuse we caught up with Kelly and his
lovely wife Cassie she's a superstar in
their home in Nashville for an honest
conversation about the singer's path to
sobriety
for me it happens all the time Charles
Kelly has seen the highest highs as
one-third of chart-topping country Trio
lady a how many grams is one seven two
three yeah seven I know but Kelly says
behind the scenes his relationship with
alcohol was taking a turn for the worse
I remember joking you know everyone uh
With Buddies I was like yeah I'm
definitely a functioning alcoholic and I
said I know I'm going to have to stop at
some point but that's not today and that
was always kind of my little joke it was
like that tells you I kind of knew
Kelly says his bandmates Hillary Scott
and Dave Haywood knew too I think it was
about
gosh it might have been about five years
ago now where where Dave and Hillary had
set me down it's the first time that
they had
really you know I mean we would have
shows or like I mean you might have had
a little too much to drink that night or
I was like okay well has it affected my
how hard I work has it affected the
shows and what did they say to that I
think it was more just I'm worried about
you and and to me I think if I remember
correctly it was more about how I would
speak to them when I was drinking it'd
be very dismissive very quick
um you know there was never any any
physical stuff but very emotional and
verbal just
I think Outburst I could recognize that
that was alcohol induced for sure Kelly
also revealed how his wife Cassie said
that his drinking affected their
seven-year-old son Ward Cassie would
tell me some stories about how little
things that Ward would say
um
that I I didn't even know he was
noticing you know Daddy daddy's talking
a little funny or you know you and Daddy
are
y'all argue a lot but just to hear Ward
said daddy's talking a little funny what
did that do to you that crushed me
absolute you know things like that just
you know he's he's the most important
thing in my life hands down no you you
said that you you had tried to quit
before yeah but you've never tried this
way what was the difference between what
you did before and what you did this
time well I mean I'll admit I went to a
rehab facility for a month and um you
had never done that oh my gosh I was
scared to death I'd had several people
and several therapists suggested and I
said no I'll I'll never ever
go into a rehab facility I was like
that's for people that wake up in the
morning and you know they're in the
sidewalk yeah they're pouring up you
know and what I've learned is there's
degrees of Alcoholics you know I think
that's one of the things too that I want
to even share is like just because
you're not
living on the street or you're not
waking up in a bush like some stories
you may hear it can get there and it can
get there really easily and and it's
like no one that starts drinking just
you know starts at the time it's just
this gradual thing and so
um but for me putting the tools in what
are your tools a lot of a lot of
meetings I go to a lot of uh group
meetings with with other other
alcoholics and I've got a um a case
manager I even I mean I'm not even
ashamed admit it I've got this little
device I blow in every morning and every
night and it's not even for me it's for
my wife it's for the band it's for
everyone else to know because I think
are you checking alcohol yeah and so
slowly but surely that has built the
trust back that eventually I think that
won't be a necessity we asked Cassie to
join the conversation to discuss the
journey she learned is just as much hers
one thing that I was shocked about when
I first when he was in rehab and I went
out there for family weekend
um you know one of the first messages
you receive is you're going to have to
do just as much work here and I remember
being so mad thinking I don't have an
issue well right like you did this and
now I have to do all of this work too
but the truth is that you know they call
it the family disease of alcoholism and
it affects every person in that family
system so I could have chosen not to do
the work but then I have to live with
the way that I've been affected and
unhealed so whether Charles and I were
in a marriage or not whether I saw him
again for the rest of my life
I still had to deal with what I had gone
through why did you stay Cassie
um I know you love him but why did you
stay you know sometimes love isn't
enough well I don't think love is always
enough I mean I think a marriage is
built on a lot more than just love
um but I think ultimately when I thought
about
well we have a seven-year-old
um who is either going to be in my home
all the time or he's going to be half
the time in a home with his dad where I
have no idea what's happening in that
environment
and in order for me to take myself out
of his life every day it just was never
got to be that bad
um until it just is you know
um and and that's kind of where we were
leaving Greece Charles describes what
happened during that trip basically we
had gotten an argument and I like just
turned my phone off
in a you know
bill of nowhere and just took off and
stayed up drinking with all these like
random people I didn't know had you know
that you didn't know and like I was and
and just literally woke up like
she woke up at what like seven enough
and went to sleep oh because he didn't
come home yeah wives don't like that but
we had got an argument and I I had one
of those moments uh where I just was
like I'm so sick of being told what to
do and I turn off the phone and I didn't
realize I had eight eight of my friends
looking for me all night Cass says that
was almost the beginning of the end the
next morning
you know I said you need help you have
to deal with this
um and he said he knew and he made a
plan with his manager to and he flew
directly from Greece to treatment but at
that point I thought I was fully flying
back to the U.S I was going to meet with
a divorce attorney like that was it how
do you think Charles when you hear that
she was thinking about a divorce
attorney I mean I guess again it just
makes me feel so grateful at how close I
came to losing it all and um I think the
thing that's hard is to know how how
much it affected Cassie the most in my
band and the people around me and how
much it like it emotionally kind of
wrecked them for a while and that you
can't really say I'm sorry enough and
it's just it's just going to take time
to rebuild that
[Music]
Charles Kelly's road to recovery
includes therapy sessions with his group
just last month lady a began their new
tour at the historic Ryman Auditorium in
Nashville where Kelly sang a song that
he wrote the name as far as you could he
calls it his goodbye letter to alcohol
cause you've taken me as far as you
could you could hear the interview what
were you thinking as he was talking yeah
I'm really proud of him
yeah thank you
um because you know it's not easy to
walk through and it's not easy to
you know
stay connected and just put your head
down and do the work because it is a lot
of work and you know because he keeps
showing up every day I get to keep
showing up every day and um our family
gets to be intact so I'm really really
proud of it yeah and like I said I mean
I I couldn't do it without without her
support I really think no Charles Kelly
you are deeply loved you must feel that
I do I feel a lot of love
yeah
yes
oh hmm truly Bravo to them both lady a
is back on stage and they have a rule no
alcohol on the bus no alcohol on the
road no alcohol no hotels but he said he
doesn't want people to feel weird
drinking around him because he's all for
drinking responsibly yeah that's he said
you know I don't want people when I walk
in the room they're holding it behind
their back lady has songs like it's a
quarter after one I'm a little drunk and
I need you now right they're going to
still keep singing those songs he said
because you know I I am changing and I
just choose to choose my friends
differently behave differently and he's
all for people who were okay with
drinking you know I'm happy that he's on
the road to recovery but can I just say
Cassie her strength is blinding yes I
mean the fortitude and the strength to
keep that family together and to stick
around when people are going through
difficulty because if she said she was
done and done and he knew that too yeah
but you can't do it for Cassie you can't
do it for your favorite son you have to
do it for yourself which he's doing but
he doesn't want to do anything that
jeopardizes his family and frankly
jeopardizes his career so they're solid
but it still takes a lot of work and
they both know that and they're prepared
to do the work I got a lot long road
ahead but they're on the road and that's
the important part yes I appreciate that
they let us come to their home and they
were both both so candid and honest with
us cheering you on Kelly's cheering you
on you and Cassidy always if you or a
loved one are experiencing a problem
with alcohol please know help really is
available via the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
line the number you see on your screen
and we'll put it up on our website
because nobody can write it down this
quickly you probably only have a pin
1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-help